[Music
] artificial intelligence is a
set of mathematical techniques that
make it possible to give machines
to computers the ability
to perform complex tasks, for
example tasks of recognition
or perception of complex environments
that can be used to
automate checks on
critical parts or perform functions
of autonomy and piloting assistance
artificial intelligence has
new characteristics
the main one is that in many
cases learning algorithms are used
which are based on
large bases  of data these algorithms
are complex are not always very
well known in their behavior
therefore the prediction of their performance
is a challenge the industrialization
of artificial intelligence consists in
making possible the application of the
concepts which are developed at the level
of research
l  aeronautics is a field of
security and trust, so it  it's
not just a question of showing that
an artificial intelligence technique
can produce results, you have to be
able to implement it in
a fully mastered way to do
this, the novelty of the challenges
specific to these techniques must be
developed  new methodologies
and processes that will make it possible to
carry out in a systematic and
totally controlled way the transition from a
new technique to its
industrial application for aeronautics
in most uses we
will need artificial intelligence
says trust why
because we  we are in a field
where safety is essential
so we cannot take
algorithms on which we have
uncertainties on how it will
behave in the hateful case at the nautical
imagined that we have an algorithm in
the plane which helps the pilot  to make
decisions if this algorithm behaves
in unexpected ways and leads to an
accident  t if acceptable so we have
a level of additional requirements
which is linked to the criticality of our
applications
it requires us to have total control
of the behavior of the algorithm
this is what we call the
trust algorithm
[Music  ]